هذا احد اهم مفاصل مراكز الصناعه القرار
الامريكي وهنا تحتضم معركه الانتخابات
النصفيه
الديمقراطيون ياملون ابقاء سيطراتهم على
الكونغرس بمجلسين الشيوخ والنوابه
الجمهوريون يسعون لاستعاده الاغلبيه ان لم
يكن على الكونجرس بغرفته فمجلس النواب على
الاقل
كل عامين يخوض كافه اعضاء مجلس النواب
المكون من
435 مقعدا معركه انتخابيه لاعاده الترشح
الديمقراطيون يشعلون الان 220 منها مقابل
212 مقعدا للجمهوريين اضافه الى ثلاثه
مقاعد شاغره يحتاج الجمهوريون الى خمسه
مقاعد فقط لنيل الاغلبيه في مجلس النواب
اما مجلس الشيوخ فيتالف من 100 مقعد ولايه
العضو فيه سته اعوام لذا يخوض ثلث المجلس
كل عامين معركه اعاده الترشح هذا العام
تتركز المنافسه على 35 مقعدا واحدا وعشرون
منها يشغلها جمهوريون واربعه عشره يشغلها
ديمقراطيون
المنافسه لنيل الاغلبيه بين الحزبين في
ثلاث ولايات هي جورجيا وكانسلفينيا ونفادا
كما يحتدم السباق ايضا في كل من اريزونا
ووسكونسن
كي ينالوا الاغلبيه يحتاج الجمهوريون الى
الفوز بمقعد واحد فقط فمجلس الشيوخ الحالي
منقسم بالمناصفه بين الحزبين مع كون نائبه
الرئيس الامريكي كامله حارس الصوت المرجحه
لكافه الديمقراطيين
يتولى الكونجرس الامريكي يسن تشريعات
والقوانين لتصبح نافذه بعد ان يمررها كلا
المجلسين ويوقعها الرئيس كما تعود
للكونجرس مسؤوليه تمرير موازنه تمويل
الحكوميه
الاختلاف في عمل المجلسين يكمن في ان
لمجلس الشيوخي سلطه النظر والتصديق على
ترشيحات الرئيسي للقضاه والمناصب الحكوميه
اما مجلس النواب فلديه سلطه بدء تحقيقات
قد تفضي لتوجيه المجلس تهاما لرئيس البلاد
احد المسؤولين بانتهاك القانون ومن ثم
محاكمته في مجلس الشيوخ